[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back top the record
where we talk about whatever we want
here we have Gilbert's gallon yeah it's
gonna dun dun dun
thank you Joe for doing it right he's an
actor and he's also part of the tiger
belly podcast slash Bobby Lee's punching
back yep and one of many one of many
first in this episode is brought to you
by upstart are you tired of applying for
loans and then getting turned down all
the time because then you have a cookie
cutter loan formats what upstart is the
first AI lending platform and that
sounds for artificial intelligence and
it's designed to improve access to
affordable credit they go beyond the
traditional credit score when assessing
your creditworthiness and reward you on
things like education job history in the
form of a smarter interest rate pretty
much all these other things that are in
the cookie cutter loans they'll look
into all that and go okay we can give
you this much money that's right they
make it fast simple and easy to check
your rate in just a few minutes
the best part once the loan is approved
and accepted most people get their funds
the very next business day that's crazy
I never had a loan that that work that
way but anyways over three hundred
thousand people have used up start to
pay off credit cards or achieve their
financial goals so free yourself from
the burden of high interest rate credit
card debt by consolidating everything
into one monthly payment with up start
and CY up start is ranked number one in
the category with over three hundred
businesses on Trustpilot in a hurry to
up start comp slash record to find out
how you can lower Oh to find out how low
your up start rate is checking array
only takes a few minutes and won't
affect your credit again go to upstart
dot-com slash record our e c.o our D the
link is in the description box below and
thank you upstart for sponsoring this
video thank you I actually am gonna go
get get alone now
were you gonna use me I'm gonna get a
personal loan I just like loans yeah I
like money sir what do you do with this
money I want to have it yeah I just want
it it's cool to have cash I will say I
like it I might get one just to hold the
cash mm-hmm can I just say
your outfit right now if you were black
you'd be an RN via video thank you
that's amazing what
but a 90s R&B nineties R&B you would
always I wish I had a fan on me at all
times I think I've earned it get very
Backstreet Boys thank you daddy and ad
jeans on - Wow maybe my red shoes maybe
but now that doesn't matter what's Nicky
proud of you Neela mornings she was yeah
well this is the official debut of this
shirt does that work thank you cuz I
wear three shirts so this is my fourth
shirt your closets growing yeah what's
the brand like once a month what's the
brand it's a brand like yeah it's like a
dad brand thing like that
Brad vacation - vacation maybe - yeah
like you shot that big and tall big and
tall do you know that big and your last
book do you or do you need to shop at a
big and tall store no what's the cut
option two targets five oh it's hard yet
target fight yeah I saw it
yeah I go to the big and tall session no
there's actually a store called big and
tall yeah yeah yeah like we will go
there to get baggy pants whatever you
would go for like baggy khakis and stuff
like that what size what size do you
wear
were you wearing that it was in the 40s
remember the length but it was just no
the width yeah it was like 40 something
yeah I'm like a it would be like a 46 or
something and I'm like a 31 or 30 oh my
god how did you keep it on that's crazy
you sure I did you got stuck on me once
when I was trying to pee you over back
Kwasi and what the belt you know the
cloth belt have you seen it it's like an
initial belt like no doubt would wear
like ever like Punk's it's like a it's
like that boat buckle where you like put
the metal and you slide it like [ __ ]
metal partner dock and I have to pee so
I'm gonna pee in my pants
Wow hey man I just don't wear the Bell I
don't anymore
oh it's army Bell that's what it is
right it's an old military building yeah
it's like a military style belt yeah
so that your [ __ ] transition yeah
it's a military belt what have you been
up I got transition from he just no but
but it you can have me hangin with the
military belt good
that's motorboat if what do you think
about the whole Iraq situation there's
more I see the correlation there's
military Iraq Iraq
yeah that was smooth and it's really
relevant to because we're only gonna be
at work I know it's a good record but I
wouldn't ask either one of you about
Iraq
why were you were you nope why not
because both we don't give a damn about
the war
that's why well I mean it's just that I
got bored of that conversation I wanted
to find out what you've been after the
conversation about the clothing I used
to wear FUBU all the time and I remember
getting beat up but you guys are
forgetting I grew up in Georgia right in
an all-white black school right so it
was either white people black people yes
but I only hung out with white people
but I'd be the Asian guy wearing FUBU
with the white people uh-huh so the
black guys beat you up kind of Chi would
be kind of how do you get didn't did
they beat you up to take it from you
well your white friends are white blue
blue - no just me don't worry about it's
a style choice I think it kind of beat
up you look well combined like mm oh I
had a really book bag right okay you
were begging for it you deserved it you
got you thought you were better than the
other kids [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you if you love your shirt thank
you well I like your hat but funky girl
you should have got scoliosis like the
rest of us for wearing the [ __ ]
backpack not one [ __ ] shoulder do no
wrong book bag I be I would always get a
bullet for that we get
no you enough says did you have oil the
wheels no so it made a lobby for two
sometimes carried a briefcase you such a
loser dude you're a [ __ ] certified
[ __ ] but did your did your parents just
want you to go get your ass beat all day
but person knows [ __ ] look like a
briefcase in a FUBU outfit Jersey right
like gonna put an American like the red
white and blue ma big zero five you got
the long black shorts past the knees but
then I'll wear those we're like Sperrys
because I didn't have money to buy like
cool kicks shoes like the type of boat
shoes like I had boats for my pay less
or something that was on you could you
sense berries but girl yeah well cuz you
had enough money to buy food oh no my
grandma died for me oh yeah from like
Marshalls okay also it was like older
yeah okay look at being attacked from I
grew up in Georgia in America but I look
like an immigrant yeah okay so what what
happened like what did they come up and
be like was that does that mean I was
like an immigrant little bit yeah yeah
what my face all of it like the Hat like
all of it right now
this is kind of a Filipino deadhead it's
always a gun hat they don't know you
look like a Filipino tuna fisherman
right now okay first of all I thought
you said you look like a Filipino tuna
and I didn't know what that racial
slicker was I was down to have his back
say anything I was like what the [ __ ]
what would you have followed up with it
and I want a fish for you you do look
like a Filipino two-minute horizon
question are two completely unrelated
how do you feel about our involvement in
Syria yeah we should be out of there or
in Oh so I like to play are you in debt
Gilbert
because you can use out stars I'm not in
there okay cool
Congrats thank you sir out of home under
them I met a homeowner roommate IRA my
roommate is a magician at the Magic
Castle
whack okay okay the Magic Castle that's
different oh because he's a professional
he's good he's friends with Shin Lim so
he's kind of like that circle did at
first Asian a magician to win America's
Got Talent
that's awesome Izzie that the JK fan
that came to our office huh I don't know
who that is
never mind he was the youngest one okay
okay he's a youngest one too they might
have been Justin Lin no no Kevin do all
Asians something okay well no they don't
look alike okay don't even say that in
this room that's [ __ ] up but there are
a lot of Asian magicians now I don't
know where that's dope I like magic it's
a virus hey guys there's a pandemic
right now there's a lot of Asia magician
he wants it to stop your job white
magicians is a mainstay copper yeah yeah
I thought that was like a like a joke
like they're appearing out of nowhere no
I'm just tired of it I don't go back to
the night is a basket I'm still I'm
still curious about how the hell did you
get your ass kicked for wearing FUBU
like did they come up you know I I do
like I didn't talk or admit or any of
that I just wore the clothing because my
cousin Chicago war so they just smacked
you in the face
Chicago my cousin my cousin the state of
the city of Chicago basically no they
just like hit me they kick the Royal
bookbag they'd hate my baby like it's
the Rowley book by are used to be
throwing zero unless they told you
specifically you can't wear that it's
not the FUBU it's the Rollie if that's
the first item that they kid that's you
got [ __ ] up for that my friend switch
your [ __ ] memories man it wasn't the
fugu ever the know they're all booked
back was closed was Detective when it
comes to this [ __ ] I know what they're
targeting you for and it's not racism
it's nerdism
and we have very thin skin here and we
get very triggered by Rolly backpack so
we'll say yeah that's one my church my I
didn't know that about you know it's
mine too what did you guys don't have
normal book fact did you yeah absolutely
all right like foreigner pounds of books
in there and I carried in around like my
grandfather and his grandpa he read
books in your backpack you were nerd -
dude where what do you mean you can go
to your [ __ ] locker there's no
tolerance in your book bag then no books
I could write notes one pencil that's it
number two mechanical were we talking uh
mechanical for sure and you got to do it
like this yeah make the strap as long as
possible you sag your pants and your
backpack the goal and then you only wear
on one side lectures oh no but by the
time I went to high school to have it
really high up you gotta walk like this
that's sick now put that down on the
ground with Sparrow my god minutes late
again you know whatever said I didn't
walk sick no one ever said that who are
you one of those kids that as soon as
the bell ring for lunch you [ __ ] ran
down the hallway with your [ __ ]
Rollie back he's pretty wack he admits
it look at mouth did you get good grades
no is that okay I like to side with the
summer school I would I went to summer
sea not a nerd
oh yeah geek just maybe immigrant maybe
there's an american-born immigrant that
stuck at school what the briefcase was a
briefcase for the briefcase my dad had
it and he was told me like this is the
briefcase I use what I was a lawyer in
the Philippines
and I thought I was like you know I'm
gonna be lawyer in the Philippines and
that which means nothing and I could
keep just like folders and papers but
had nothing do with school they're just
to have a brief you're so weird
hey guys that's so I said American porn
I think you didn't brush your teeth
right now yep
no no no you're a weirdo born weirdo hey
are you were you an Asian kid were you
an Asian kid born in Georgia for racing
towards my mom trust me like how like I
used to get a Kohl's gift card and she
would dress me like I was a [ __ ]
little dad yeah the only thing the
[ __ ] beeper on my [ __ ] to school no I
don't get a belt yeah I was worn using
the new basically sorry what the lawyers
in the Philippines argue over like sir
he stole my coconuts he broke the
coconut with his feet that might be no
they my dad said well he was also mayor
two of the small town but we ran man
what he told me though it was like he
never had to do anything legal or
anything before the community you tried
to but it was run by the mob so
basically money under the table just
keeps [ __ ] cool and he's like [ __ ] this
I'm going to America and that he'd be
and I worked at a gas station mayor
they're not taking a degree legal
degrees from the Philippines
I keep the tech I'll be able to banana
leaf with your signature on oh I swear
to God yes he worked at a gas station
and that was like for like almost 10
years and he had he was a lawyer in the
mayor and that was a culture shock he
moved in those thirty oh it's like
hotshot women all the time Monday under
the table and then she'll so he's the
crazy
gas station worker that's like did you
know that I used to be mayor my dad just
like he would do a lot of jokes to
that's how I got into stand-up was cuz I
wish I could show you guys it's all his
first joke I think was like hey everyone
my name is Gilbert Galan or you can say
Gilbert forecourts
Gallo no yeah but the crowd know the
crowd courts for courts guys a crowd
goes nuts because of his accents the
accent yeah that makes sense
so it's just a bunch of dad Filipino
jokes oh yes a lot of stand-up
what does he look like to me
we're winning and we're gonna keep
winning born in Chicago moochick move to
Atlanta when I was six
during right before the 96 Olympics so
before Atlanta became cool and safe ah
and then I moved to LA I moved back to
Chicago to do second city rose 20
dropped out of school good stuff for
Asian parents and then move to LA five
years later why did you think he was
kalila as cousin he's like uh so when
when we by the way I find he was
Vietnamese so I was like we had this
conversation cuz Bart was like I think
he's clients cousin I'm like nah bro he
can't be he's Vietnamese so I first of
all wouldn't you be the reason that's
trash
you're clearly insulted by them gave you
Vietnamese impression no I mean I don't
know I forgot but I just the whole time
I was like he can't because I'll is
cousin cuz he's Vietnamese and then he's
like nah dude I think he is but yeah
that's that's how it all that's where
this is cuz the first time went on Tiger
belly
Bobby came to the parking structure he
gave me and then he was smoking a
cigarette and
then actually we're done what done the
tiger belly and then we went it went to
the parking structure and then Oz oh
cool how did you get all this like
podcast stuff started because it was
just you know clients buckled I thought
people there's a lot without support so
I just got that because I don't even
just for me I just just for everyone
around oh [ __ ] I was like oh I guess
it's this family you know I you think
this is this is the girl I'm dating this
is this gotta be you gotta be related to
collab so yeah so then you go in there
and you're gonna quietly like I'm so I
got this so crazy so like come on I met
koala through Jenna I don't of you guys
know Jenna yes she was not yes I didn't
mean it oh yeah no I think they were
gone the day that she came in yeah but
we know who she is yeah so I'm Jenna I
know her from Chicago she was actress we
met out here and then she's like oh I'm
friends with this girl named Kyle you
should meet her I'm like cool so we met
with her and we just started talking we
bonded over MMA cuz we're like huge MMA
fans and then she was like hey I'm doing
this podcast with my boyfriend am i cool
she's like do you know anything about
like audio I was like no but I noticed
things about computer I can help you set
it up so they cool do you mind like
coming and like hitting start and stop
we just are trying to figure it out was
it cool and she's like oh by the way my
boyfriend's Bobby Lee I'm like [ __ ] and
I just moved to LA and I was trying to
figure out like how do I like get
involved with the comedy scene stuff
like that right there and Bobby [ __ ]
my eyes for a full year basically tried
to like bury me and like he hated me
like actually hated me loves me now but
he just thought I was trying to like
sneak in and like just kind of like
sneak into what Carla's [ __ ] okay
he then I was trying to [ __ ] kalila one
and then to you she thought when I
[ __ ] my cousin's [ __ ] and then two he
thought like I was just trying to like
ride his coattails or I'd be one of
those like young comics I just want to
like jump on a comic right then he
realized I wasn't a stand-up comedian I
was just there to help yeah so any kind
of went him over that way and he forced
all of us to do stand-up and that was
kind of like his okay cool stamp oh oh
it's like ouch yeah so like I just and
wioletta stand-ups her sister did
stand-up George does stand-up I know if
you guys heard ha
you're Bobby's crazy that's tight we
heard that you coached him on it oh man
that Steve Rico George Kim well I've got
berated bunny Pete dick you guys seen
the tape
no you guys recorded it yeah all set up
dude where did he do it's really good a
good review laughing in the back row so
I got there only all the way to Irvine
improv packed crowd 700 people Oh George
how did he even get a crowd that big
Bobby mr. Bob Oh George was doing uh
Gabby made them open for him yeah well
George calls for him but similar idea
basically
Bobby typically makes us like open up
from do five minutes and then George
usually asked us he like forces us but
he never forced storage I don't think
you wanted George George stepped up
because everyone's gonna do it kept
asking if he could do five and then
Bobby that she was like cold you could
do five I'm stirred up and I'd be like
epic ten milk get there Bobby I go to
the green room and in Georgia goes Bobby
goes like we have to go outside I don't
he's like he's one of those weird people
he's like I don't want to watch it but I
want to watch it it's like hate him yeah
he goes outside we send the side George
actually gets a couple laughs cool and
then me Bobby
Bobby's literally grabbing me like this
it's shaking like he's just nervous it's
also like his child but he also want
them to fail it's very weird it's all
confused cuz he's like you're not one of
those comics I wanna open for me are you
you have to open from me on my next show
yeah but don't [ __ ] up but also you need
to bomb but don't please cuz you're on
tiger belly so it's like that whole
energy but it's really just the energy
of a personality disorder
oh yeah pretty much yeah so George kinda
he was doing well like got it and then I
would say a minute or two minutes in I
think he got cocky maybe like he does
the doors you know I don't know what
he's working on hey [ __ ] then yeah
that's the George cocky and then he
starting to start pacing around in a
circle like a shark to hunt just
circling around the mic and then the
audience I think just lost him and then
you just hear Bobby every time a pledge
light is supposed to happy Bobby goes
the best thing would be though wouldn't
this be the best thing if we could pack
a whole stadium for George and have him
do an hour and everyone's in on it and
everyone's laughing no could George
would love it he would not yeah this he
would love it yeah
yeah yeah you're [ __ ] with George's
[ __ ] ego but you're not even [ __ ]
with him either you're kind of like
stroking his dick a little bit he wants
to succeed and he's kicking ass saying
you tell the art you make the audience
laugh at everything guys no it's not
[ __ ] up cuz then then Bobby will be
[ __ ] pissed
ya know and he's there passive George
I'll say why Bobby was still pissed from
this kind of because typically when you
bomb you're like [ __ ] I bought you hate
yourself right a compa class to be like
see that's it's a tough thing to do yeah
George came into the room and Bobby goes
how'd you do
bye George goes all the other comics
that were like featuring like comedians
they're all like what and then Bobby
lost his [ __ ] what do you do he's like
destroy him
no no George no I don't know absord like
mine [ __ ] Bobby to piss him off I think
George Eliot thought he did okay but
he's such a positive dude but you know
what he did it that was the thing that
Bobby loved we all loved that he went up
and annex a lot people just don't do it
yeah so how do you guys don't stand up
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] about it now
you're gonna do it technically no I've
never done like stand up stand up
oh you're still fine I've done like
speaking gigs and stuff like that but
that's totally different
how did years ago I look pretty good I
think I did a couple of shows maybe like
10 to 15 or open mikes uh yeah I did a
comedy store the Laugh Factory I did oh
whoa first I did it was just when we
first started youtube there's all those
like the old-school comedians that are
like oh you guys are real comedians you
guys can edit and hide behind a computer
screen and for me I'm like a very pay my
dues to have a person oh my [ __ ] you
guys I'm gonna do stand-up - and then I
was like I think it's more fun to make
the video
and have hundreds of thousands people
watch it they go on stage and only wait
300 people see I really respect the
crabby hundred to craft but like there's
not enough people there for me but I
think it's so cute what you guys are
doing that stand up I have yeah sure
yeah but I never I never I kinda used to
improv four nights a week for [ __ ]
ten years not do that with stand up with
what school are you CB and I did comedy
sports in San Diego hobbies course guy
yeah that's where I started that [ __ ]
that's how you make money short form to
long form yeah
fun stuff wait but I never fell for it
the same way as improv as far as damn
close
[Music]
[Music]